hey it's jenna here if you have been
experiencing constipation bloating gas
headache fatigue eggs low energy bad
breath or food cravings regularly while
these are some signs that your body may
be toxic overload a healthy digestion is
essential for your body to absorb all
the good nutrients and eliminate the
waste that we don't need
these detox drinks will help kick-start
your metabolism burn fat reduce bloating
and as a result you'll have a flatter
belly all you have to do is add all the
ingredients into a glass chill in the
fridge for a couple of hours or
overnight and enjoy
[Music]
cucumbers are diuretics which were
cleansed of the liver flush our bodily
toxins and prevent water retention the
acids in lemon juice helps slow down the
digestion process which increases
nutrient absorption
better nutrient absorption means less
bloating mint has an anti-microbial
properties which can be used to support
oral health giving you fresh breath
[Music]
green tea is known as a superb fat
burner it increases the body's fat
burning ability curb appetite and
reduces cravings apple cider vinegar
keeps the body strong by helping the
body to maintain a healthy alkaline ph
level so this drink can help to increase
metabolism and speed up weight loss
[Music]
apples are extremely rich in
antioxidants and they are delicious
cinnamon manages blood sugar levels
reduce sugar cravings so you won't be
munching on those sugary treats
[Music]
ginger will help flush out toxins in the
colon liver and other organs which
supports the entire digestive process it
also reduces the accumulation of fat
especially fat that is stored around the
belly
[Music]
if you want to you can also add a
teaspoon of honey or maple syrup into
the mixture stir
and enjoy chilled you can steep the
mixture for another 2-3 more times
before it loses its taste
so consume these detox drinks on a
regular basis for a healthy digestion
these drinks will promote a more active
metabolism and help burn fat more easily
but remember guys you won't magically
lose weight just by drinking this and do
nothing you will still need to maintain
an active lifestyle and eat a
well-balanced diet so try these detox
drinks drink them every day and let me
know which is your favorite in the
comments below be sure to like this
video share this video and subscribe to
my youtube channel for a lot more
healthy recipes and also workout videos
do also turn on your notification button
so that you will get notified every time
i upload a new video all the best